hello I'm Peter Walter I work at the
University of California at San
Francisco and we are basically sabato
just trying to figure out how cells work
specializing on organelle biogenesis and
how proteins get to the right place and
how they function and ultimately we
would like to understand how proteins
work as molecular machines to make cells
as wonderful and as complicated as they
are so what I want to tell you today is
a brief story of discovery I think one
of the most wonderful discoveries that
was made in my lab in my career and it
involves the reaction by which cells
decide how much of a particular
organelle they have to have in the
organelle that I'm going to tell you
about is the endoplasmic reticulum which
is the first way station which proteins
enter as they move through the secretory
pathway to the surface of the cell and
are being secreted or inserted in the
plasma membrane the endoplasmic
reticulum then is this is the place
where proteins have to they enter the ER
they have to fold they have to become
assembled from multiple subunits they
become modified baby carbohydrate is
added sulfide bonds are formed and all
of these reactions are important to
produce properly functioning proteins
and cells that are specialized that make
a lot of proteins and secrete them have
to have a lot of endoplasmic reticulum
in order to carry out these processes
with fidelity and Andres appropriate
appropriately abundant machinery the
proteins enter the endoplasmic reticulum
unfolded state as they come out of the
ribosome and then as there are in this
organelle they basically have to mature
and if they cannot fold properly then
cell basically a-put puts puts proteins
in its plasma membrane or secretes them
and and because all the machinery that
that is required for a cell to know
where it is in the body what it has to
do how it has to behave in the context
of a multicellular organism all this
information is being transmitted by
proteins are being
treated or by the machineries that sit
in the plasma membrane so it's it's very
very important that these machineries
work properly are properly assembled
because otherwise you may create a rogue
cell that doesn't know when to divide
when to differentiate when to die when
to migrate to another place and so on
and so forth so so for the organism this
is a very important process and this is
sort of amplified in this slide where
you look at the differentiation of a
cell a precursor cell here that turns
into a professional secretory cell in
this case it's a plasma cell and the
plasma cells are the cells that make
antibodies that are being secreted in
the bloodstream so the cell makes its
own weight every day in antibody
molecules and you see that this
differentiation event goes hand-in-hand
with this vast proliferation of
endoplasmic reticulum that basically
fills the cytosol wall-to-wall so how
does this he'll know how much
endoplasmic reticulum it needs so there
must be signaling pathways in the cell
that figure out how much of an organelle
we have and how much is should be there
according to the needs of the secretory
load that the cell has and this
signaling pathway that transmits that
information which we've been studying
for the last 15 years or so is called
the unfolded protein response and it's
called the unfolded protein response
because it initiates with an
accumulation of unfolded or miss folded
proteins in the endoplasmic reticulum
and these proteins they're unfolded
because there isn't enough capacity to
fold them properly from the machinery
these proteins then create a signal
that's being transmitted across the
membrane of the endoplasmic reticulum
that ends up eventually in the nuclear
compartment where it turns up a vast
gene expression program that makes
basically more endoplasmic reticulum
protein folding capacity secretory
capacity capacity to great proteins that
cannot be folded properly and so on and
so forth so it brings cells back into
Homo static a homeostatic state that
allows the load of secretory proteins to
be balanced with the machinery well
to carry out that task to figure out how
this pathway works to very adventurous
graduate students in my lab Jeff Cox and
Carolyn Shamu started a project in which
we tried to identify these components
genetically in the yeast system and
basically what they did is they built a
reporter system based on an observation
made by Kathy toshimori and Mary Jane
guessing in Joe Sam Brooks lab that
there is a small element in the
promoters of the target genes of the
response that can be transplanted can be
put in front of a reporter gene and then
we can isolate mutants in the cell where
when we ask when when we induce unfolded
proteins in the ER that no longer induce
the unfolded protein response by this
induction of this reporter gene we can
then take these mutants we can clone the
genes that have been mutated by
complementation and figure out what they
do in the password and the nice thing is
that the first gene which we isolated
this way turns out to be IA 1 and it
encodes the transmembrane kinase so by
virtue of it being a transmembrane
kinase it already told us that this that
this may be the signal transduction
device sitting in the our membrane
figuring out in one end what's going on
there and transmitting that information
across the bilayer very nicely is the
second gene we isolated turns out to be
hacked one and hat one encodes a
transcription factor that binds to all
these promoter elements so we then have
transmembrane kinase we have a
transcription factor and of course the
way we're thinking about that it's very
much an analogy to other transforming
kinases like growth factor receptors in
the plasma membrane of mammalian cells
that this thing is activated and
functions by a process of all
accumulation in the plane of the
membrane we are in the unfolded proteins
accumulate these kinase molecules come
together they start bringing the
kindnesses together on the other side of
the of the membrane where they're now
juxtaposed so that can trance or
phosphorylate each other and that
somehow leads to a phosphorylation
cascade downstream that activates the
transcription
factor but turns out that it nothing
could be further from the truth this
password is wired in a completely
different way in a completely unexpected
way and that was discovered pretty much
by a series of controlled experiments
that Jeff carried out and he is the
first one where we very simply very
naively just started looking for the
transcription factor in cells that are
either induced for the response or that
are not and as you can see here the
transcription factor is only present in
cells when the response is induced so
that tells us two things right then in
there right means either degraded when
it's not needed or it's only synthesized
when it's event when the response is
induced and to distinguish between these
two possibilities what Jeff did is he
just did a simple northern blood
analysis by which he asked us a
messenger RNA encoding this
transcription factor change in its
abundance when we induce unfolded
proteins if you see here the messenger
RNA doesn't really change much in
abundance but what you see when what
Jeff discovered here is that we now have
a band of a different size that was
completely unexpected so the simple
northern blood then led to the discovery
that there is something happening to the
messenger RNA and to make a long story
short it turns out that this messenger
RNA becomes spliced and in turn is being
removed when the unfolded protein
response is induced so the idea then is
that the messenger RNA encoding the
transcription factor is initially
encoded with this intron and as the the
unfolded proteins accumulate this intron
is being removed producing the spliced
messenger RNA which is then being
translated to produce the transcription
up factor that turns up the response now
this is highly unusual
normally when cells decide to change
their transcription to their splicing
program to some alternative splicing
they make reasonably irreversible
developmental decisions so that they
last
long time they enter different cell-fate
business decision but this is bonafide a
signal what's happening here is depend
strictly dependent on the conditions
inside the endoplasmic reticulum the
signaling is on and off depending
whether you have unfolded proteins or
not what's even more surprising is that
this splicing reaction followed none of
the rules of non messenger RNA splicing
it's completely independent of the
spliceosome it's happening in the
cytosol and it's carried out by two
enzymes and two enzymes only the first
one turns out to be ia one our
transmembrane kinase when activated
becomes a by functional protein that is
not only a kinase but also site-specific
end of our nucleus that cleaves the
messenger RNA encoding the transcription
factor precisely at post splice
junctions and to best of our knowledge
is the only messenger RNA in the cell
touches and then along comes an enzyme
called DNA ligase which was previously
only known for its role in T RNA
splicing and we had isolated a mutation
in that and another graduate student
camel acid ruski and we couldn't make
any sense out of that until Jeff had
discovered that this is RNA processing
step in this signaling password so the
unfolded protein response and transmits
the signal by assist is unconventional
completely unprecedented na a splicing
pathway and there is no phosphorylation
cascade anywhere inside here let me just
show you this is true we can make this
messenger RNA in vitro we can incubate
it with recombinant Lea produce IR a 1
and you see that the messenger RNA gets
cleaved producing the intron 5 prime X 1
X on and then as we add also recombinant
we produce purified T RNA ligase to this
reaction the the exons go away and get
like Ida to form the product and the
intron stays put so we can reconstitute
this whole pathway from two purified
components whisk whisk whisk whiteness
efficiency we make a long story short
this discovery then led to
to many other labs and it turned out
that pretty much everything the salient
features that we've learned from the
simple yeast system hold true for
mammalian and metazoan cells so this one
exists in metazoan cells it is involved
in the splicing of a messenger RNA
encoding a transcription factor x b p1 x
b p1 here things are more complicated
higher above eukaryotic cells have added
more bells and whistles to the pathway
so we have three parallel pathways here
that transmits information from the
lumen to the cytosol each leading to the
activation of a transcription factor we
have ie one working by this
non-conventional mRNA splicing we have
another transforming kinase here perc
that makes another transcription factor
by a mechanism of translational control
and finally we have this exciting
protein here that sits in the membrane a
tf6 and then gets released a fragment of
it gets released to become an active
transcription factor that moves into the
nucleus and turns up the target genes
only invent unfolded proteins are
accumulating in the endoplasmic
reticulum and the idea of the whole
thing is the same as I told you before
is to establish re-establish homeostasis
so protein folding in the endoplasmic
reticulum cannot curve as fidelity so we
have these three pathways here and they
establish homeostasis but I also tell
told you that there is a danger that if
cells are cannot achieve homeostasis
that that they may make mistakes in
protein folding and therefore turn into
rogue cells that endanger an organism so
there's a safety valve built-in that if
this balance cannot be achieved again
that cells rather than putting these
these misfolded proteins and misfolded
signaling machines on the cell surface
go down the pathway of apoptosis so
rather than becoming rogue cells and in
dangers of the the organism they remove
themselves by committing suicide and is
this this this point that the this the
unfolded protein
response makes life death decisions for
the self that puts this pastor in the
midst of many different human diseases
some cancer cells are kept alive because
the response gives them a growth
advantage diet and diabetes the beta
cells in the pancreas may die through
this a pathetic road here by being over
committed to produce Everly ever
increasing amounts of insulin and way of
neurodegenerative diseases where protein
misfolding causes apoptosis by turning
up this response so basically then our
very pioneering the pioneering work of
these very adventurous graduate students
has led us to understand the mechanism
that we now be and many other labs try
to to utilize in in syrup utak
approaches to see if we can have some
ability of bettering mankind via by
interfering and modulating these
pathways and therefore affecting the
outcome of human disease
you